when somebody becomes a president or a
prime minister
how much do they care how the economy in
that country does
during the eight years they're the
president versus how the country does
100 years later
well
at this point it doesn't seem like many
presidents especially in the
english-speaking world give a damn about
the eight years they're in power
i mean we've got a ski instructor ski
board instructor running canada we've
got a half demented person here with a
vice president that can't string two
words together properly running the
united states of america
boris johnson thankfully is gone but
who's going to replace him and the
australia has just brought in this weird
government colombia has brought a weird
guy as well they're just bringing weird
people left and right i guess the
qualification is
to become a man in powers to be a little
bit weird maybe that's what they're
looking for i just don't understand why
there aren't more qualified people
seeking these positions but then again
maybe not many people actually want to
heat no not not just the heat it's it's
uh
fear it's the freedom it's life is a lot
easier then let them deal with the
problem i guess the point i'm trying to
make to use the following how many
people that become president sit there
and say
i want to create policies
that 10 presidents from now
makes america a better country or how
many presidents get up and say hey mary
can you tell me my approval rating this
morning oh [ __ ] okay let's go tell them
we're going to give a billion dollars of
subsidies to papa papa
went up to 41 you're no longer the worst
president of all time like meaning what
i'm trying to say is
how many presidents actually give a [ __ ]
about what's going to happen 100 years
you're not going to bring up the t word
are you what's the t word
the next letters are
treason
trump no no no no no is that a bad word
in your mind no it isn't because i asked
people not why do you hate him
why what policies that he brought in
during his tenure do you disagree with
and
i don't know what the answer can be he
he the policies he brought in
were about the future and we're about
the economy and we're about the people
and we're about to see the southern
border and we're about energy
independence and we're about whatever
i don't know of a bad policy that he
passed and biden comes in and just rubs
them all out with a stroke of a pen on
the first day and causes an energy
disaster and an afghan disaster
afghanistan disaster and all these other
disasters and he still has 25 approval
rating i mean that's a good thing
because that means he has 75 not good
approval rating but
i just don't understand why the hate
happened
i it it makes no sense to me because
hate is not a good reason to be against
a person
especially if they haven't done anything
wrong
and
it's been proven eight or ten times over
that he didn't do anything illegal or
wrong but they went after him like as if
he had
robbed the bank you know and
i i
i am very unpopular for even ever
mentioning his name even in my own
country of canada oh we talk about him
all the time you're you're in safe space
here but we'll get back to that because
he's got some things he'll say too about
that but let me let me finalize the
point i was trying to make here's do you
know what point i'm trying to make the
point i'm trying to make i think i want
to know how many people can live on
earth if we keep going this direction is
that not what yeah so my point is the
following here's my point
no matter what country you look at when
it comes down to elections
how many of those presidents are
concerned about what the country's
legacy is going to be 50 years from no
zero they care about their eight years
that's left or right i think what you're
getting at whether you're not whether
you're this is any country in the world
of course you care about your power now
zero to do with left right middle zero
this is not like this is why we need a
libertarian president i'm not doing that
at all all i'm saying is the current
structure of any leadership in any
country is what how is the market going
to do while i'm there right okay isn't
that the same for any ceo though
quarterly earnings
not founders ceos yes not founders
because founders live forever ceos don't
okay founders level you can't you can't
name every ceo of mcdonald's but you can
name the founders sure right you can't
name you you found you can name the
founding fathers you're going to forget
a lot of the presidents if i told you
who's the 19th president you may not get
it right but if i tell you who's a
founding father you're probably going to
get it right so so the point i'm trying
to make you're saying the founding
fathers have a vision the ceos are more
concerned with that quarterly
if they're watching what's going on are
devastated because they're founders
they're like dude we put this together
for it to work and you guys are breaking
this thing founding father founders are
different but that's the point so if you
look at right now worst case scenario
according to the math
that we just did
when is the next double going to be
when are we going to go from eight
billion to sixteen billion total forty
years i believe okay so worst case how
many years sixty years what's 60 years
from today 2080 and how long will it
take to double again after that we don't
know so but but we based on data you
keep going back to data it's not based
on data you're projecting the future by
past data and you just use a bunch of
past but i didn't predict the future but
you have to predict the future no you
can't but no no it's not you can't you
can't but you may be wrong you can
that's what visionaries do you're more
than likely to be wrong well george
orwell
somehow got it right yeah some people do
get it right in 1984 when it was wrong
when he wrote the book a lot of people
said he's a fraud exactly okay so let's
play the game of let's forecast and see
what could potentially happen and it's
okay if we get it wrong just like george
well got it right
if we do forecast
in 60 years we're at 16 billion if we do
forecast and i'm comfortable being wrong
in 120 years right 32 billion you won't
know whether you were wrong or not i
don't care if i you know why the human
species would cease to exist
i sell life insurance okay all right
do you know what age you're gonna die i
don't know what age i'm gonna die nobody
does nobody does but guess what it's
better off having it in case you do that
so your family is protected yeah so i
want to sit there and say okay for the
people that are using tactics to win
elections today
that's not climate change shouldn't be
the number one priority of any campaign
should it be a top 10 thing that we pay
attention to that we have to figure out
a way not even the word climate change
is not even on my priority it's what's
the plan to know what the capacity of
this you know planet is what is our
capacity we need to know those numbers
what number can we not touch so if you
like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]